tell us about the interview with the
Rolling Stone magazine so that was it
was a kind of a weird can all day
interview yeah so when Rolling Stone
does a cover story it's like they say
hang out you know you hang out with this
journalist for a couple days and they
just you just hang out if you drive
around they're sitting there you go to
lunch
we hang it's like a thing and it was a
huge deal for me to have a cover of
Rolling Stone it still is like for me
that's like oh like it's a big angel
singing moment and so of course like I
was just like be your best self today
like be like if you're gonna drive you
drive the best you've driven like I also
you're like how do I be real and not
like be pretending to be real like when
I'm clearly like I know this is a
journalist like cool but do all that I
was just like okay so I'm gonna take him
on a day that I it's this journalist
named Brian Hyatt who's the coolest and
like take him on a day I'm going to
rehearsals it's normal and I'm just
gonna drive him cuz that's what I
normally do be your best self at driving
and I got in to car accident one was my
fault one was not one wasn't I'm sorry
the second one was a year welcome I
saved your life
swiped but I was like I was fully
panicking and when we got side so I
think he screamed out something like I
have a new baby at home
good cover story for me like this is
gonna be good for people reading it but
not for me
[Music]
you